welcome back our next guest is someone
i've known for a very long time i've
watched her
become an
editor-in-chief
a talk show host a judge on one of the
biggest fashion shows in the world and
the longest running a best-selling
author
and now i'm so excited to see her bloom
into her latest role
mom to be
and from our studio in los angeles
please welcome my dear friend the maven
elaine walter roth
hi drew
oh rain
oh i'm so happy to see you
how are you gonna make me cry already
it's like been three seconds and i'm
already like oh god
because you're pregnant and emotional
i'm pregnant and it's crazy that you're
the first person i'm talking to about it
i feel so grateful for the opportunity
to be the first show that you are
revealing this talking about it sharing
um everything because i loved what you
put out on instagram and you're such a
pioneer in the field of social media and
you put this beautiful film out i don't
know how you have like this editing team
literally it's a beautiful film that you
put out to announce your pregnancy will
you tell me about
choosing
to
make your announcement in such a
cinematic poetic personal way with a
particular piece of music that was very
important too
well i mean first of all thank you i
haven't heard it described that way it's
so moving i was like i probably should
like
i don't know come up with something cool
like a a cool way to share this because
it's so special it's so intimate um and
so actually my friend lena weith
uh who is a tv maven film maven she was
like oh i got a team she was like you
got to use my boys and so she hooked me
up with this amazing video editor and we
just sent him like all of the random
kind of iphone videos that we've been
capturing throughout this journey
um
while it was still a secret and they did
an incredible job every time i i look at
it i cry like it's the first time like
it's just it makes me so emotional even
jonathan he's a musician he made this
beautiful lullaby and we used that for
the video because i was like you know
that's that's the perfect that is the
perfect thing we have to we have to
share this with the world so to be able
to share that felt so so special and
people have been so kind and i just feel
grateful to be here with you i felt so
safe talking to you about it you are in
thank you so much you are in such
safe company i mean there we go there's
me pregnant
um i'm i'm i'm
that's my yoga mat that i i guess i
chose not to bother rolling up
um
and there i am carrying life dragging my
yoga mat but i just like you know i'm
gonna show this to elaine because all
the great photos and
bliss and i mean i was like job at a hut
on like
steroids of just i was like
i was like
and then everything i did was just eat a
lot and just sit there
and you know i was lucky enough that
this carcass that i've totally damaged
over my life was able to give me two
children it's a miracle
and
i got you a gift actually no
yes um no you did not yes i did okay
so
i got you this pack and play i by the
way i became a real gear head okay i got
you the dome sound machine this
changed my life and some people are like
leave the windows open make noise like
don't have a you know a baby that's like
can't handle light and noise i was like
turn 15 of these on
and don't tell me how to raise my baby
okay um so i got that for you and then i
i picked up the peanut this didn't exist
but it's my favorite changing oh my god
and the and and your little one will
just love it
it's like it's just a miracle it's the
best little changing pad and they they
get really attached to it
and all of
the babies know now this is my favorite
pack and play and now
i'll tell you why maybe i'm just messy
it could be me oh
it's that thing
it's all taped down and like okay see
this is why i love this pack and play oh
my god um
sorry
i didn't know they were gonna put all
the straps on okay see okay auntie drew
is killing the game already this is
crazy
[Applause]
okay i want everyone to see this you
take a pack and play somewhere and
you're a world traveler like you're cool
and i bet you're going to take your
little one with jonathan and travel the
world i've tried every pack and play
this one is my absolute favorite
stop it
stop it you're like santa claus for
pregnant ladies only one that's like
this
boom
[Applause]
i'm just so excited for your journey i
had to get you my three favorite items
that i learned about as a parent for
babies
you are the sweetest human in the entire
world
i love you
i am definitely gonna prime my eyes out
when i leave here
thank you so much my mom is definitely
crying right now watching this this is
unbelievable you are the you are the
best thank you so much drew i can't wait
to watch the latest season of project
runway my very favorite show on
television
i am so thankful because i need this
show in my life and i can't wait for
this season
thank you so much it's gonna be the best
season yet i have to tell you i can't
there's not a lot i can tease but it's
gonna be really good well i'm so glad
that it's back on bravo thursdays at 9
00 pm i will be there on tap every
single thursday at 9pm
[Music]
you